ينضم الينا من الجبيل الكاتب الاقتصاديه
السعوديه فضل البعني سيد فضل مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
الفائض الميزانيه لاول مره يسجل في
السعوديه منذ تسعه اعوام الناتج المحلي
كسر ترليون دولار للمره الاولى تاريخيا
وكذلك نسبه انه تخطط الثمانيه في المئه ما
الذي يمكن التقاطه من اداء الاقتصاد
السعودي هذا العام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يمكن التقاط ان
الاصلاحات همم الهيكليه في الاقتصاد
والاصلاحات الماليه بدات تعطي ثمارها بشكل
اكبر همم واضح ان القياده السعوديه اصبحت
اكثر تحكم في الاقتصاد وفي الجانب المالي
خاصه وان النتائج التي نراها اليوم كانت
ايجابيه عندما نتحدث عن تجاوز حجم
الاقتصاد السعودي تريليون دولار لاول مره
فهذا امر في الاهميه
ويجعلنا قريبين جدا من تحقيق هدف رؤيه
المملكه 2030 في ما يتعلق بحجم الاقتصاد
السعودي ايضا عندما تحقق الميزانيه العامه
فائضا ب 102 مليار ريال همم بعد اكثر من
تسع سنوات من العجوزات هذا يؤكد بانه هناك
اصلاح تم تنفيذها والتنفيدها ونتائج
ايجابيه تم تحقيقها ايضا في الجانب الاخر
اعتقد ان تحقيق التوازن المالي بات امرا
مهما كان من الم طب همم ان يكون موعد
تحقيق التوازن المالي هو 20 23 فالحمد لله
انه تحقق في العام 20 22 وبالتالي الحكومه
اليوم متقدمه على الاهداف التي رسمتها لها
رؤيه المملكه 2030 جانب مهم اذا سمحت لي
فيما يتعلق بالبطاله وانا اركز على هذا
الجانب اقل معدل البطاله خلال 20 سنه وصل
الى 9.7 وهذا مؤشر ايجابي على ان سنصل الى
7% في 2030 باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى تفضل
ماذا عن مراحل الانجاز ايضا كذلك بالنسبه
للمشروعات
التنمويه بالنسبه للمشروعات الخمسه الكبرى
همم ايضا اسال كذلك عن المشروع الاكبر
والاهم الذي اعلن هذا العام في اليوم وهو
دلعي
طبعا
كما نعلم ان هناك اكثر من مشروع من
المشروعات الكبرى على سبيل المثال ليوم
الكبرى و ايضا البحر الاحمر مشروع البحر
الاحمر مشروع القديه كل هذه المشروعات
كبرى داخل هذه المشاريع مشروعات اصغر ايضا
تتشكل من خلالها هذه المشروعات الكبرى
واشرت انت الى ذا لاين الذي اطلقه سمو ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وهي المدينه
الذكيه التي ستؤسس من الصفر همم
الاصطناعي والذكاء التقني وبالتالي وخفض
ايضا معدلات همم
التلوث بل اننا نتعامل مع مدينه يفترض ان
يكون مخرجاتها صفر في جانب تلوث البيئه
هذه المدينه تحت ظل انشطه كثيره من ضمنها
الذكاء الاصطناعي الاقتصادي السياحي
الترفيه انه جسدي وكل هذه الامور
تكنولوجيا الحديثه انا اعتقد انها هذه هي
مدينه المستقبل خاصه انها المدينه الاولى
التي نفس همم في العالم وبالتالي المملكه
ستكون قائده في هذا القطاع خاصه وانها
ستنشئ في نيوم وبالتالي سيكون هناك تكامل
في المشروعات هناك ايضا المشروعات اخرى
مراحل اخرى في القديه على سبيل المثال
المرحله الاولى في 20 23 وهذا امر مبشر
بالخير ايضا بالاحمر هناك بعض الجزر التي
تم او شكل او شركه الحكومه على انجازها
وهذا ايضا غايه في الاهميه ومن ضمنها ايضا
همم جزيره سنداله التي تم الاعلان عنها
مؤخرا وهذه السياحه الفاخره في العالم
ستكون
ستقطبقات همم استثماريه اضافيه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الجزيره